bonjour c'est marie-hélène bienvenue
dans l'atelier les petits bricoleurs
aujourd'hui nous allons réaliser un
panier de pâques
alors pour ceux loi pour cela nous avons
besoin d'une feuille cartonnée d'une ans
cartonné toujours deux attaches
parisiennes du raphia des crayons de
couleurs bien sûr mais quelques peines à
la neige de la colle aux plis war une
performeuse des ciseaux un stylo et en
décoration une poule et 1,9 donc la
feuille j'ai fait comme dimension j'ai
pris 38 à 30 et on va séparer en trois
ensuite on va couper cette partie d'un
projet 6 euros couples ont fait ici
aussi pareil il refait aussi dans
l'autre sens ensuite on va marquer les
plis donc on prend une règle et omar
bien les plis j'apprends le le pli war
on fait bien le play voilà donc ça
devrait faire ça
l'étape suivante vous fait rentrer la
partie du centre on ramène la partie
latérale comme cela on fait une pointe
et on va coller alors donc aimé de la
colle et on remet le pointu l'un et
après on prend une pince à l'aise on me
lapp
pour bien tenir et on refait la même
chose de notre côté
alors ensuite on va jouer ouvert à tous
et lance alors cela on va perforé la
première perforeuses pour mettre avec
les attaches parisiennes mais si vous
n'avez pas davantage parisienne pouvait
très bien coller donc je vais mettre
lance là je regarde le niveau je
performe voilà et ensuite je mets la
tâche parisienne
voilà ce que ça donne et on refait
l'autre côté voilà on va passer à la
décoration
donc je vais choisir une poule dans
titeuf
alors on va colorier pour moi j'ai
choisi le jaune je ne va pas vous
colorier a choisi la couleur donc vous
souhaitez ensuite on va colorier la
poule aussi joyeuses pâques on à paul et
maintenant décoration donc on a mis les
décorations là chaque côté maintenant on
va prendre le raphia content d'être à
l'intérieur du familier
j'avais tout ça voilà le panier étant
terminée ne reste plus qu à les remplir
avec des oeufs au chocolat et je vous
dis à la prochaine émission avoir des
joyeuses pâques